was von out innen und astronauten
leisten wirklich beachtlich ist jetzt
die fünf außergewöhnlichsten leistungen
den weltraum bei pixum science fiction
den längsten außeneinsatz im all
absolviert
susan helms und dem fonds im jahr 2001
endet der er erst nach acht stunden und
56 minuten 380 kilometer über der erde
helfen sie beim bau der internationalen
raumstation iss sie wechselten
kabelleitungen aus montierten eine
antenne um und bereiteten alles für die
montage eines greifarms vor dafür
mussten sie fast eben neun stunden am
stück außerhalb der iss bleiben bis
heute war kein anderer mensch länger am
stück im weltall in einem raumanzug also
in einem außeneinsatz als die beiden
wieder in die kapsel zurückkehren
wollten mussten sie mehrere stunden in
einer druck schleuse ausharren der
körper musste wieder an den normalen
druck angepasst werden kleiner fakt noch
zur fertiggestellten iss die raumstation
umrundet die erde
16 mal am tag
der erste mensch auf dem mond war neil
armstrong betrat am 20 juli 1969 den
mond sein berühmter satz damals das ist
ein kleiner schritt für einen menschen
ein riesiger sprung für die menschheit
was viele vergessen
er war damals nicht allein was ortwin
stieg nach dem aus der mondfähre zu ihm
herab auf dem mond gemeinsam waren sie
die ersten menschen dort heute gibt es
jede menge gerüchte und spekulationen um
die mondlandung viele kritiker
bezweifeln dass diese echt war
allerdings konnte die nasa bisher alle
zweifel ausräumen
keine der verschwörungstheorien war
bisher stichhaltig
für susan helms und james vollendete
hier außeneinsatz erst nach neun stunden
der russe sergej krikaljow war zwar
nicht die längste zeit außerhalb einer
raumfähre aber die längste zeit
überhaupt im weltraum sergej krikaljow
mehr als 800 tage im all verbracht
also mehr als zwei jahre seines lebens
über der erde im weltall auf diese
aufenthaltsdauer kam er bei insgesamt
sechs flügen der längst aufenthalt eines
westeuropa ist übrigens fast ein jahr
der deutsche astronaut thomas reiter
flug zwei mal ins all
dort angekommen verbrachte er insgesamt
350 tage in so vielen film sieht man
immer wieder astronauten durchs all
schweben die meisten davon schreiben
ohne sicherheits leine durch die gegend
wenn man aber mal eine sicherheits leyen
in einem film zu sehen bekommt dann gibt
es direkt irgend eine schlimme situation
ein drama spielt sich ab das war
übrigens auch in der realität beim
ersten weltraumspaziergang so alexej
leonow war der erste mensch der das all
betrag mit hilfe einer sicherheits leine
kurz nach dem ausstieg aus seinem
raumschiff bot zwei spielte sich ein
drama ab nach 20 minuten musste er um
sein leben kämpfen sein anzug verhielt
sich plötzlich wie ein riesiger ballon
er pustete sich nach und nach auf am
ende seiner kräfte angelangt schaffte er
es gerade noch ins raumschiff
der erste mensch auf dem mond der
längste aufenthalt im all der erste
mensch außerhalb eines raumschiffes all
diese leistungen basieren auf dem
erstflug ins all aber wer war eigentlich
der erste mensch der in den weltraum
führung viele nationen also vor allen
dingen natürlich die usa und die
sowjetunion und die wollten die ersten
sein es gab einen richtigen wettlauf
zwischen den beiden und geschafft hat es
schließlich die sowjetunion juri gagarin
begab sich am zwölften abrivard 61 auf
den weg ins all innerhalb von einer
stunde und 40 minuten flog einmal um die
ganze welt danach kehrte gagarin
unversehrt zur erde zurück es ist
wirklich unglaublich seit wann wir
menschen schon die möglichkeit haben ins
all zu fliegen
heute wissen wir schon so viel über das
was weit von uns entfernt ist und doch
wissen wir noch lange nicht alles in nur
wenigen wochen konnte man erklären wie
das weltall klingt mehr dazu erfahrt ihr
im video hier oben
klingt das weltall in diesem video hört
er tatsächlich aufnahmen aus dem all zu
rap und zum block kommt ihr hier unten
und kennt ihr noch mehr derartige
leistung schreibt wir uns gerne in die
kommentare unter dieses video vielleicht
machen wir noch eine folge 2 mit
außergewöhnlichen leistungen im weltall
vielleicht habt ihr so das ein oder
andere geheimtipp ziehen oder so eine
verborgene höchstleistung dann schreibt
sie uns und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran